traditionally the stock traders job has
been to analyze charts company
fundamentals and news announcements
but more often these days they're called
upon to be computer experts
on europe's exchanges about a third of
all orders are now submitted by high
performance computers
these computers are programmed with
algorithms to make buy and sell
decisions thousands of them in
milliseconds in an effort to squeeze
money out of the smallest price swings
the faster the processor the higher the
profits
this is high frequency trading and even
the electronic routing of the data can
make a difference
finance expert hans peter berghoff is
looking into the ways high frequency
trading affects market
high trends trading can execute many
transactions with a speed human beings
can scarcely imagine
we're talking about speeds in the range
of 10 to the power of minus seven or
eight seconds
so a computer can shoot off an order to
the market and then send a replacement
order right after it with 10 to the
power of minus 8 seconds in between
nobody even sees the buy or sell orders
and they're already gone
in worst case scenarios automated
trading can cause sudden drops in the
indices
in 2010 the dow jones plummeted over a
thousand points within minutes
in the united states over half of all
market order decisions are fully
automated if left untouched by human
hands can the system fly out of control
situations keep recurring where the
computers miscalculate the figures
because of some inefficiency or other
and suddenly the market can drop by a
few thousand points
it's critical for both sides to be
continuously adjusted
peter bayer has been trading stocks for
deutsche bank and commerce bank for more
than 30 years
he's just started using a new trading
platform that combines both human and
computer strategies
he thinks it's a bad idea to leave stock
trading up to machines
it's been my experience that you have to
have a very good technical model as a
basis for utilizing all the information
you need to bring whatever trading
skills you already have to bear
that's a basic condition the automated
strategies completely leave out the
emotional aspect of it
there are also strategies that combine
man and machine
but i say machines are unable to learn
to spot a trend over time or changes in
trends on the market
some exchanges prohibit high frequency
trading stuttgart for one
here only human traders can handle the
orders from private investors but that's
hardly viable for the big exchanges in
london and new york
i don't think high frequency trading
should be prohibited
it should be regulated so it won't pose
a danger
but we'll have to put lots of thought
into what kind of regulation that might
be
it's too easy to just require all the
books to be opened and collect all the
information it's going to take a bit
more bureaucratic efforts
new european union guidelines are
tightening the regulations for high
frequency trading
in the end it all comes down to money as
long as computer trading turns a profit
it will be done
you